let's speak now to deputy prime minister
and justice secretary
dominic raab thank you very much indeed
for being with us let's just uh
work out where we are here there's a 40
mile column of putin's armor just
outside this uh capital about to lay
siege
to kiev a capital of a free democratic
country and the west is
not going to stop him how does that sit
with you
well i'm not sure i'd accept that
characterization first of all we pay
tribute to the heroic defense
which bit of the characterization
which bit do you allow me to explain
that they're there or that the west is
going to stop them can i give the answer
and then you can pick pick up on any
aspect of it
first of all
we do pay tribute to the heroic defense
uh by the ukrainian forces and their
fortitude in the face of outright
aggression from president putin our
viewers the uk is that
putin's mission in ukraine must fail
i don't think it's right to say that
we've done nothing to
stop or curtail what putin is doing i
think if you look at not just the suite
of sanctions on oligarchs
and on banks and on the russian state
but also the impact that the collective
action has had including on the central
bank and on the swift payment system
we've seen the the biggest fall in the
ruble against the dollar uh we've seen
the stock market in russia fall to
record lows and the central bank in
russia have to double interest rates and
that is all part of the uh allied uh if
you like the the the uk working with our
international partners efforts to starve
putin's war machine
and it does have an impact and of course
it's your correspondence with respect um
just with respect to um mr rob i didn't
say you were doing nothing to stop him i
said you were not going to stop him he
is going to
surround this capital lay siege to this
capital and i asked you how it sat with
you that that could happen nato has the
most powerful air force in the world
and this is happening in a european
capital in 2022.
well of course
ukraine's not a member of uh nato uh
we've been clear about that in terms of
military participation but what we have
done is armed uh something like twenty
thousand uh ukrainian uh troops we've
sent two 000
anti-tank missiles we've provided a
package of support 100 million pounds
and of course allies and partners have
done uh further um support we yesterday
announced 40 million additional in
humanitarian assistance so we uh
along with the sanctions suite and it
has had an impact in the way i described
on putin
but we know that we putin will react to
this or we fear that putin will react to
this with even more barbaric tactics
and that's why we need to be prepared
that this could be a long haul and we
will do everything we can to achieve our
goals of making fruit insane you seem to
be saying
yeah but you seem to be saying that
there's less of a moral case there's
less
of a humanitarian case there's less of
an urgent case because ukraine is not a
member of nato isn't a humanitarian case
and a moral case absolutely urgent now
and does it matter really that it's not
a matter of nature it's not a member of
nato
i think the the the the the
the nato is incredibly relevant in terms
of how we apply uh the the principle of
collective self-defense of course it is
um but what you're right to say is that
morally we feel a strong duty to do
everything we can to degrade putin's war
machine hence the sanctions i describe
the impact they're having also the the
efforts we're taking to support and
steal uh the resolve and the defensive
uh capabilities of the ukrainians uh
which we've done in the way i described
on top of that the humanitarian support
and we're working with our international
partners i think it's been a pretty
clear um and concerted response but your
argument mr rabb your argument seems to
be that you know the argument for not
acting is that it could start another
world war or heaven forbid some sort of
nuclear war well then is what is to stop
president putin going on to attack other
countries just using the same nuclear
threat even countries that are members
of nato
well i i the the what is to stop him is
that this is turning into a much much
more perilous uh misadventure for putin
than i think he realized and as your
report made clear it has had a
demoralizing effect on russian forces
some of those young conscripts and it
has had uh
the effect of stealing the will of the
ukrainian people and that is how we will
ensure putin fails in ukraine and uh we
are there for the long haul and that's
why i mean again uh with some of these
very brutal tactics that we're seeing
being reported including by sky news
with the harrowing pictures that we will
see in our uh tv screens and in the
newspapers i think we've been very clear
that um those that engage in war crimes
will be held to account and the icc
prosecutors exactly that's that's
absolutely it there are war crimes
happening right now in this country
children are dying schools are being
attacked a kindergarten has been
attacked and the west is sanctioning
russian banks and kicking russia out of
the world cup
yes and but no more than that actually i
mean i i totally accept what you're
saying
this is the uh barbarous consequences of
such an appalling aggressive action by
president putin which you're not wishing
to stop which you're not stopping
so forgive me you're interrupting me at
every step and you're you're frankly uh
following this on the 24-hour news cycle
which i understand is your liberty to do
what we've said we're going to do is
degrade putin's war machine by starving
it of the finance necessary to operate
and actually if you look at the
short-term consequences the effects on
the ruble effect on the stock market the
doubling of interest rates in russia it
is having the effect that we want and it
is turning into a very very difficult
campaign for putin one which and we've
always said this will be disastrous for
russian uh for putin and for the russian
people but i do think we'll need to have
the stamina to be in this for the long
haul uh and that's why making it clear
both to putin but also to commanders in
moscow on the ground in ukraine
that they will be held accountable uh
for any violations of the laws of war
and we've shown the west has shown that
we're willing uh to to to see this
through we will not just look the other
way we had radovan karadich the butcher
the balkans end up in a british jail
cell via the hague recently
and that message will go uh to those
commanders on the ground in moscow as
well as back to uh
in ukraine as well as back to moscow and
there will be accountability uh for the
for any crimes that are committed on
ukrainian soil
and for vladimir putin accountability
for vladimir putin um when it comes to
war crimes
well
that is there as well uh he is
ultimately the person in charge uh via
command responsibility and so that is
very much a factor and this ought to
play into his calculations along with
the fact that uh as you as your reporter
uh uh quite rightly said and your your
clip were quite rightly said this has
not been the walk in the park that he
expected uh either in terms of uh
ukrainian resistance uh or the
effectiveness of his own tactics so all
of these things will slow down and we
hope uh encourage change the calculus
and get him to step back uh and
again we take these actions and the uk
has done a huge amount it's been in the
vanguard the prime minister the defense
secretary the foreign secretary
but we do this with our partners and we
are willing to to be in this for the
long haul because i suspect
notwithstanding the initial stuttering
putin will respond uh
and try seek to respond in ever more
heavy-handed ways with the appalling
humanitarian consequences that we'll
have
so what about the idea of enforcing some
sort of no-fly zone to some sort of
humanitarian corridor would you support
trying to enforce a no-fly zone here i
think the defense secretary has already
been clear on that uh we're not going to
do that because it will be put us in a
position where we would have to enforce
it by uh
in effect shooting down
russian planes what we are doing is the
measures that i describe to you on
sanctions on supporting the ukrainian
resistance and on the accountability
piece which i think will be even more
important
and we'll hear more about that in the
days and weeks ahead
how long does british intelligence think
that
um kiev the capital city here can hold
out
well i'm not going to comment directly
on the intelligence we get but it's very
difficult to to say um the
russian initial advance
has been slowed down more than they
expected and that is a testament to the
ukrainian uh fortitude and courage and
what we want to do is do everything we
can to delay uh the um the fall of kiev
uh or any of the other major cities in
ukraine and we will continue to look
with our allies and every means of
achieving that so to make sure that
putin fails in ukraine it's critically
important that's our strategic objective
okay well i mean if he i suppose if he
takes um kiev he gets rid of the
government he occupies this country i
suppose he'll consider that he hasn't uh
failed but are we being a bit
mean-spirited
on visas do you think i wonder
a 75-year-old woman living
now in a basement in the capital here
who has her son living in london
can she
go and join him
so just on your first point i i you know
if putin occupies kiev one or other of
the major cities
that doesn't mean this is over because i
think what you'll see is uh ukrainians
uh bedding down for some form of uh
guerrilla um uh uh challenge which will
take a lot longer and could well be uh
unresolvable from the point of view of
putin's military objectives and indeed
your
your clip showed that in terms of the um
the question of visas and ukrainians the
home secretary has uh set out the plans
for a bespoke humanitarian um scheme for
ukraine allowing up to a hundred
thousand to come here the dependence of
british nationals in the uk the
dependence of uh ukrainians living in
this country
and i think that's the right way to
approach and it follows uh the wider
action how does the 75 year old woman
sorry sorry to interrupt you but how
does the sirens just going off here but
how does a 75 year old woman living with
sirens going off living in a basement
get to her son who's living in london
can she do that is she able to do that
because i can't see how she does how
does she go to la vie of 11 hours drive
away get a visa and then it just doesn't
make sense i don't see how she
can get to her son in london
under the current system well
this is a a consistent feature whenever
we have humanitarian asylum schemes set
up we know that the difficulties on the
ground make it practically very
challenging
but we also know that many will uh get
out of ukraine those that uh uh fleeing
through fear uh and we need to be ready
with our international partners the
europeans uh others around you who are
saying anybody any ukraine can come in
any ukrainian come in for up to three
years or certainly extended family
members other countries are doing why
why are we not doing more
i mean that
we we've set out about the 75 year old
woman is a real one yes but i can't
comment on every uh potential
hypothetical case what i've just set out
is the circumstances and of course we
understand the difficulties of the
practical situation on the ground that's
common to most uh uh
conflict zones of course and we
recognize that we'll work with all of
our international partners and the un uh
to try and resolve that and to to to
make sure that we continue this
tradition of of of offering haven to
safe haven to those fleeing persecution
in relation to the europeans of course
they're closer to ukraine um uh and uh
as the ukrainian ambassador the uk said
over the weekend uh it it will often be
the case that
first priority most ukrainians want to
stay in ukraine but if they leave they
want to be as close to their their home
country as possible uh in order to be
able to come back at some point in the
future so i think i don't i think this
woman wants to get to see her son in
london but you know i mean she doesn't
want to go to poland to stay in poland
she wants to go and see her son in
london
in fact the case but it's clear from
what the home secretary announced
yesterday that that we would make that
uh route technically open of course it's
very difficult to know how exactly she
would um traverse the country at that
age
but but that is the offer that home
secretary has made so actually it
directly addresses the scenario you've
described
okay uh dominic rob i appreciate you
being with us we're
slightly distracted here by sirens but
listen i appreciate your
talking to us this morning good to talk
to you